es el final del mes sagrado del ramadán
pero los disparos siguen sonando en la
ciudad de jartum a pesar de que las
fuerzas paramilitares han anunciado una
tregua de 72 horas con el ejército
sudanés
La tregua coincide con el bendito e idal
fitir para abrir corredores humanitarios
para evacuar a los ciudadanos Y darles
la oportunidad de saludar a sus familias
es el tercer intento de alto al fuego
después de que otros dos esta semana
fracasaran en su intención de llevar la
paz a Sudán y renovó los llamados de la
comunidad internacional a una tregua
antes de ir el jefe del ejército sudanés
se dirigió a la población
confiamos en que superaremos esta prueba
con nuestra formación sabiduría y fuerza
preservando la seguridad y la unidad del
Estado
el general abdelfata albujan lleva una
semana enfrascado en una batalla con el
grupo paramilitar FARC dirigido por su
antiguo Aliado el general Mohamed ham
dagalo conocido como hemetti ambos se
culpan mutuamente el conflicto y ninguno
da muestras de voluntad negociadora
Mientras tanto la población sigue
atrapada en el fuego cruzado
de una víctima se corta la luz hay
saqueos robos todo esto está ocurriendo
el país está asumido en un caos extremo
aumenta el temor por la situación médica
muchos hospitales se han visto obligados
a cerrar y otros se han quedado sin
suministros miles de civiles salieron
dejar tumba en medio de las explosiones
muchos otros también cruzaron a chat
para huir de los combates en la región
occidental de dafurt la Organización
Mundial de la Salud reporta que son
aproximadamente 413 personas las que han
fallecido en el conflicto